We have convened this state citizens' council to announce that we
already have the result of the primaries for the European elections.
I want to thank the more than 36,000 people who have once
again participated in this democratic process driven by Podemos.
I am deeply proud to lead 1 political organization that does what
it says it fulfills its democratic commitments and always holds
primaries open to the public to elect the people who represent us.
This is 1 of the main democratic assets that we have as an
organization and I believe that we must protect it above all else.
Today we celebrate and announce that Irene Montero will be the
ones who decide if we deserve the trust of the positions we hold.
our candidate for the next European elections in June 2,
024.
Irene and Thank you from the bottom of my heart for taking on this very
important challenge to bring back to the forefront the transforming left of
our country 1 nonconformist left that knows how much it costs to change things
and yet is willing to pay that price to improve
the lives of the people of our country.
Irene you can count on me and on the thousands of militants that we are
going to leave our skin so that this project of deep transformation this
feminist project this environmentalist and courageous project has a voice
in Europe nor also from here to miren gorrochategui and all his team that
has won the primaries of pode for the next Basque elections I think we have
1 unique opportunity that in Euskadi there will be 1 government that is
more like what the people in Euskadi vote for 1 clearly left-wing
government and for that it is imperative that the car and
whoever we can be stronger than ever.
Aurrera look And I also want to welcome the new coordinators and
autonomic coordinators who have been elected in these primaries and that
I am sure they will do an excellent job to strengthen us at the
territorial level to Isabel Serra new coordinator of we can in the
Community of Madrid to María Teresa Pérez new coordinator of pode in the
Valencian Community also to Conchi avellane who revalidates
the autonomic coordination in to Marta.
We have 1 crucial collective challenge to take our project to every
corner of this country and with you I am convinced that it will be possible.
Thank you very much and 1 applause.